oddio ciao a tutti bentornati the stars
oggi nuovo video andiamo a vedere degli
scherzi fatti con lo slime assurdi
siccome gli altri fini in cui vedremo
quindi script fate con lo stress sono
piaciuti un sacco mi avete scritto di
vederne altri schermi andiamo a terne
dei nuovi che non ho mai visto quindi
onore agiva insieme a voi e tremonti per
gli assieme su super curioso di vedere
cosa succede se state pensando ma dove
subite le lucine che c'erano di altre lo
sfondo per mi sono nuovamente spostata
non a distanza con solo di parete e
quindi devo spostare tutto perché questo
più comoda anche alla luce mi piace di
più male voler spostare tutto quindi che
vedevi pure le vostre idee su come
addobbare la farete po dietro che cosa
mettere ho letto un sacco di vostre idee
nei commenti che mi sono piaciuta
qualche penso che a trovare allettare ma
comunque scrivetemi pure secondo voi
rimettere quasi altri siete pronti come
sempre prendesse posatine tempo crosby e
mettetevi comodi video a tutto schermo e
iniziamo subito
ok per suo numero uno come sembrava la
fine del video decidere con quale è
stato uno scherzo credi scioccante
insomma quello che abbiamo cercato di
più quindi scritto numero 1 stanno
preparando
con l'altra mattina mi sembra che
abbiano missione latina però perché che
chiude il titolo lo vuole mettere nella
vasca da bagno del padre non so come
andrà a finire
vediamo ok che se bastano a mano
elettrico come garino massaggio
utilissimo e il padre sta apparentemente
dormendo perché amo conosco il
significato è allargato a rovesciare lo
shaman king
[Musica]
praticamente veramente o castano
parlando perché non sapevano di questa è
una bella faccia le sue fasi una
fantastica
questo era lo scherzoso quorum uno che
vota ok premio numero 2 canale si chiama
light cui andrebbe scherzo line sul
padre sempre inizio perché in questo
caso le vittime sono i padri poverini
vediamo cosa succede a parma ma faremo
mai un appello sul collo con quello
della polveriera in particolare quasi lo
sento l'europa avevano fatto che era
stranissimo che hanno castrato lo slime
ora vediamo
buttando addosso questi proprio
[Musica]
ma sono mai conosciuto per una cosa
molto importante
[Musica]
ok quindi quello era una discrezione al
iv anno facendo un altro con quello con
la polverina
da quanto ho capito vediamo quindi
numero 3 ok stefano un passato quando la
polverina non so solo che non lo stesso
portare alto salvate questi troppo bene
[Musica]
mentre pulisce la marchi nel padre ok
non si è accorto di niente stranamente
non sente niente
rubinho
[Musica]
a lui è rimasto ancora per il oppure che
bravo molto su questi temi come la
facciata in questi tre scherzi ora
stiamo allo scherzo numero 4 questi
strumento qui dove che stanno creando lo
slime lì per strada permettendo al collo
ma come hanno fatto con sembra il club
che l'ha fatto anche dottore anche molto
stimoli che si spacchi e che non si
appiccicano davvero ancora peggio per le
bombe mica ok è arrivata la vittima alla
fidanzata con questo è l'ultimo scherzo
e dello stesso
sulla fidanzata questo canale reale è on
line
quindi vediamo perchè sta facendo lo
stesso con della famiglia ci sono di
coniugare di tutorial su youtube e su
come fare lo slide che non vadano di
portare a roma non sottrae un pensiero
va bene è meglio anzi la fa chi ha detto
appelli degli istituti a ultimo non
accendere straducale di studio
[Musica]
definiti come sarebbe né una quelle che
mi è piaciuta di più
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la legge che signori e momenti diciamo
che forse non si toglie le cappelle news
italia press
ma basta un altro che vengono iscritte
[Applauso]
[Musica]
andiamo a vedere l'ultimo stop di altro
che portare all'ultimo ma con super
curioso di vedere questo perché e non mi
simone dal canale a mamma e jimmy
[Musica]
c'è scritto nel titolo vendetta attivare
migliorato
[Musica]
che ragazzi preti erano tutti gli
scherzi fatemi sapere che i commenti
quale abbia fatto ridere di più con le
mie due partite di più a me che ha fatto
ridere di più il primo ultimo quello con
la ragazza che si arrabbia moltissimo e
cercava di picchiarlo quando questi
tempi è divertente
fatemi saperlo è quella che ha divertito
di più se volete vedere un altro
episodio io ho altri video di slime
scherzi sono morti però non riguardano
adesso sono il video sarebbe troppo
lungo però solamente vedere altri
episodi alla società un bel live che è
fatto una costante nei miei commenti
e oramai prossimo video da vedere
un'altra simpatica céline e altre
challenge altri video divertenti
cliccateci quello che preferite e buona
visione
ma